vsauce kevin here with a game that you
can always win
grab a friend and take turns counting
using numbers from 1
to 10. the first person to get to 100
wins
which can always be you to demonstrate
let's have a friendly game between me
and uh
i guess i'll just play with myself
hey me it's good to see me
am i ready to play yes
yes i am okay add numbers between 1 and
10 and the person who gets to 100 first
wins i'll write the sum in between me's
so that you can follow along
i'll start the game one seven
four nine two
ten one you're just picking numbers
randomly like me
right uh yeah
okay cool three eight
eight three five
six seriously though we both have 50 50
odds of getting to 100 um
sure all right four seven
nine two oh wait 89
if i play one that's 90 and you could
play 10 and win and if i play 10 that's
99 and you could play one and win oh
weird i uh must have gotten lucky yeah
right
five six one hundred i win
every time here's how uh
uh you can you can go now me oh
fine well i want to rematch and i guess
i'll just see you in the mirror
yeah okay now let's play a game
between me and you and i'll explain
along the way
how it works okay the easiest way for me
to know i'm going to win
every time is for me to go first and
start
with the number one no matter what
number you add next
5 3 8 whatever it is i
just subtract your number from 11 to get
my
next play so if i start with 1 and
if you say 4 then our sum
is 5. to get my next number i do 11
minus four which equals seven so
seven is my next play seven plus five
gives our game a new total
of twelve then you say eight
cool eight plus twelve gives our game a
new total of
twenty i do eleven minus your eight
which is three so i play three
and our new total is twenty three as
long as i stick to this strategy
i'm guaranteed to be the first to 100.
this is why it works regardless of your
number
mine will always result in a sum that's
part of an arithmetic series separated
by
11. 1 12 23
34 45 56
67 78 89 and then finally
100. since the highest number you can
play in the game
is 10 if i separate your moves by
11 i rule the world or at least
this simple number game which
gotta start somewhere when you play this
game with your friend can they
ever win yes if you mess up the series
while going first playing one and
subtracting
every opponent's number by 11 is the
easiest way to stick with the series
after a few rounds of playing the game
you might want to switch things up to
prevent them from
figuring out your strategy you could do
that by
starting with a number other than one
and then choosing
wrong numbers until later in the game
when you land on a number in the
arithmetic series
like 67 or 78 so if you're playing with
your friend and you pick
random numbers until the sum is 65
well then you just need to play a 2 to
bring your total to
67 and then you're right on track from
there
just subtract your friends numbers every
single time by 11
and you will be the first to 100
to players who don't realize that the
optimal strategy depends on that series
this game seems like a game of chance
but once you know the series you have
the secret
number knowledge but if adding up to 100
isn't your cup of tea
you could try a similar game with
matchsticks
these are inks durable match-like puzzle
sticks
they come in the brand new curiosity box
that is out right now it's packed with a
booklet
that features 22 different puzzles that
you could try to solve yourself
when you get these matchsticks but for
right now we'll use the matchsticks to
visualize another game
that you can always win all right
you have 11 matchsticks spread out on a
table you and a friend take turns
removing either
one two or three matchsticks and the
player who picks up the last match
loses if you go first you can always win
this game since you don't want to pick
up the last match
let's work backwards to uncover the
secret
we'll play a game between mr t and
skeletor because why not
alright let's skip to the end of the
game to work out the winning strategy
if it's skeletor's turn and mr t leaves
skeletor with
two three or four matches
skeletor can leave t with the final
losing match so t will want to make sure
that he leaves skeletor
with five to guarantee that mr t
keeps his jewelry
here's why if there are two matches left
then skeletor just takes one and leaves
mr t with the final losing match if
there are three matches left then
skeletor takes two
mr t loses and if there are four then
skeletor takes three
then mr t loses again but
if t leaves five no matter what skeletor
plays next
three two or one t can make the winning
move
and pity the fool accordingly the
arithmetic series that will rig the game
for
t is separated by fours one
then five and then nine mr t will want
to leave skeletor with nine matches
to make sure that all his plays match up
with the series
if skeletor and t start with 11 matches
and t
goes first that means his initial play
will be to remove
two since each player can only remove a
maximum of three matches per turn you
can dominate the game
every time by going first and making
moves that stick
to this series which is why the game
works with
20 matches too to guarantee a win with
20 matches on the table your first play
should be to remove
3 to land you at 17. so let's say
t starts and removes 3 to get to 17.
no matter what skeletor does t just
needs to get to 13 to stay
on course to win so if skeletor removes
2 to get to 15 then mr t just needs to
remove 2
to get to 13. now t needs to get down to
9.
so if skeletor removes 3 to get to 10
then mr t just has to remove one match
to get to nine the next milestone is
five so if skeletor removes
one to get to eight then mr t can remove
three
to get to five and now it's officially
over skeletor can't do anything one
two three it doesn't matter mr t
is leaving skeletor with the final
losing
match let's see if it'll fit in his hand
how about this one
good enough both the counting game and
this matchstick one are referred to
as nim-like because they're conceptually
similar to a game from ancient times
that evolved into what mathematicians
now call nim
players take turns removing objects from
heaps or stacks
and the player to remove the last object
loses
but it gets a lot more complex than
sticking to a basic
arithmetic series we like
complex humans have been inventing brain
teasing games to pass the time
sharpen their minds and extend
collective knowledge for as long as
recorded history shows one of the oldest
games we know about is
senate with board pieces from ancient
egypt dating back over
5 000 years about the same time
humans were inventing the precursors to
our modern written language systems
we were developing number games to
occupy ourselves
and tease out a better understanding of
the quantifiable
world creating artificial challenges and
then out thinking them is a way we
exercise
our minds by discovering the hidden
patterns that govern reality
whether we're just practicing with a
matchstick game or
unwinding the great scientific
challenges of our times
we're engaging in an integral part of
what makes us
us even those of us who use skeletor to
explain math games and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you